hello and welcome to this video playing
FM Yvonne yeah let's key okay let's see
how I try something else Jana caller
opening not too frequently seen opening
in my games but why not some change I'm
sorry yeah I think here black has a
couple of options Queen c7a 6 h-6 there
are all kinds of moves here I've looked
at this opening for white quite a while
ago I didn't think it was so bad not so
bad at all takes with the Queen oh ok
interesting 94 or is there some wacky
tactic no way that is not right
okay let's gain some space here I Bishop
t60 threatening Bishop takes age 21 okay
doesn't do it he does not play it okay
b5 doesn't do much and probably worked
in one threatening b5 takes takes root
e7 winning a piece or group t-7s also
please somewhat somewhat of an annoyance
Jim maybe you can play Bishop f6 but I
have my doubts okay what happens here
just Bishop f4 and now I think I need to
develop check soon
okay I need to check out at be five
books I mean yeah he has no worry in the
world absolutely none okay so if i take
check and play Queen d3 isn't that a
problem the bishop is hanging on the aid
this one good move I couldn't move I
guess
maybe 95 is that working threatens I
just threaten to take the five now the
thing that worries me is my big back
rank but okay if I take well well if i
take here what happens there should be
five this Bishop f3 and that's it I have
okay so green tags I can also play g4 in
this position this also is interesting
it is actually strong I think no but I
should take here this is stronger I'm
threatening mates threatening a couple
of mates mm-hmm sorry and I'm
threatening chief one after the Queen
why I take f7 so I don't really see a
move right now Queen 88 is a threat yeah
now g4 should work
black resides ok so I don't know I don't
know what happened to you I think I
gotta go to a pretty decent position all
of a sudden this was ok for sure for
black and yeah i don't know i think
after this i have some pressure somehow
it it looks a little bit more
comfortable for wide i was expecting
this move though which has a threat at
least i have to probably spend a move
here now it's probably equal this is a
little bit more comfortable for me now
that's roop t7 those ideas and now this
is not easy to play this queen is
slightly off side the computer wants to
play rook c8 now and then aged 3 giving
why the slide edge and here i wonder if
this is actually still still playable
for black so yeah the engine isn't on a
huge advantage it seems to find a deep
chance this this this and now it wants
to play Bishop to e7 25 ok in my
original when I was thinking of you
about the student the game I thought
this would would win but there is this
move very cute I mean okay this is not
easy it's not clear that black is ok of
it it at least a move that saves them
for the moment yeah this is the thing
but might play this
yeah that might still be okay down here
95 it's is difficult it's difficult now
Queen h4 is given by the engine yeah
this is a good way it covers this and
now something like this is the line that
the computer wants to play with roughly
equal play hmm I don't know hmmmm don't
know then it's better than the game
though here I'm winning them yeah here
i'm building the double threat of g4 and
28 is is decisive yeah interesting game
hope you enjoyed it thanks for watching